how would you recommend
a person learn math
so somebody who's young or somebody my
age or somebody older
who've taken a bunch of math but wants
to rediscover the beauty of math
and maybe integrate into their work more
so in the research space
so and and so on is there something you
could say about the process of
incorporating mathematical thinking into
your life
i mean the thing is it's in part a
journey of self-knowledge
you have to know what's going to work
for you and that's going to be
different for different people so there
are totally people who at any stage of
life
just start reading math textbooks that
is a thing that you can do and it works
for some people and not for others
um for others a gateway is you know i
always recommend like the books of
martin gardner another sort of person we
haven't talked about but who also
like conway embodies that spirit of play
he wrote a column in scientific american
for decades called mathematical
recreations and there's such
joy in it and such fun and these books
the columns are collected into books and
the books are old now but for each
generation of people who discover them
they're completely
fresh and they give a totally different
way into the subject than
reading a formal textbook which for some
people would be the right
thing to do and you know working contest
style problems too those are bound to
books like especially like russian and
bulgarian problems right there's book
after book
problems from those contexts that's
going to motivate some people um
for some people it's going to be like
watching well-produced videos like a
totally different
format like i feel like i'm not
answering your question i'm sort of
saying there's no one answer and like
it's a journey where you figure out what
resonates with you
for some people if the self-discovery is
trying to figure out why is it that i
want to know
okay i'll tell you a story once when i
was in grad school i was very frustrated
with my like lack of knowledge of a lot
of things
as we all are because no matter how much
we know we don't know much more and
going to grad school means just coming
face to face with like the incredible
overflowing fault of your ignorance
right so i told joe harris who was an
algebraic geometer
a professor in my department i was like
i really feel like i don't know enough
and i should just like
take a year of leave and just like read
ega the holy textbook el amon de gea
the elements of algebraic geometry this
like i'm just gonna i feel like i don't
know enough so i'm just gonna sit and
like read this like
1500 page mini volume book
um and he was like and the
professor i was like that's a really
stupid idea and i was like why is that a
stupid idea then i would know
more algebraic geometry because you're
not actually going to do it like you
learn
i mean he knew me well enough to say
like you're going to learn because
you're going to be working on a problem
and then there's going to be a fact from
ega you need in order to solve your
problem that you want to solve and
that's how you're going to learn it
you're not going to learn it without a
problem to bring you into it and so for
a lot of people
i think if you're like i'm trying to
understand machine learning and i'm like
i can see that there's sort of some
mathematical technology that i don't
have i think you like let
that problem that you actually care
about
drive your learning i mean one thing
i've learned from advising students you
know
math is really hard in fact anything
that you do
right is hard um
and because it's hard like you might
sort of have some idea that somebody
else gives you oh i should learn
x y and z well if you don't actually
care you're not going to do it you might
feel like you should maybe somebody told
you you should
but i think you have to hook it to
something that you actually care about
so for a lot of people that's the way in
you have an engineering problem you're
trying to
handle you have a physics problem you're
trying to handle uh you have a machine
learning problem you're trying to handle
let that not a kind of abstract idea of
what the curriculum is
drive your mathematical learning and
also just as a brief comment
that math is hard there's a sense to
which heart is a feature not a bug
in the sense that again this maybe this
is my own learning
preference but i think it's a value to
fall in love with the process
of doing something hard overcoming it
and becoming a better person because of
it like i hate running
i hate exercise to bring it down to like
the simplest hard
and i enjoy the part once it's done
the person i feel like for the right in
the rest of the day once i've
accomplished it the actual process
especially the process of getting
started
in the initial like it really i don't
feel like doing it and
i really have the way i feel about
running is the way i feel about
really anything difficult in the
intellectual space
especially mathematics but also
just something that requires like
holding a bunch of concepts in your mind
with some uncertainty like where this
the terminology or the notation is not
very clear
and so you have to kind of hold all
those things together
and like keep pushing forward through
the frustration of really
like obviously not understanding certain
like
parts of the picture like your giant
missing parts of the picture
and still not giving up it's the same
way i feel about running
and and there's something about falling
in love
with the feeling of after you went to
the journey of
not having a complete picture at the end
having a complete picture and then you
get to appreciate the beauty
and just remembering that it sucked for
a long time
and how great it felt when you figured
it out at least at the basic
that's not sort of research thinking
because with research you probably
also have to enjoy the dead ends
with uh with learning math from a
textbook or from video there's a nice
you have to enjoy the dead ends but i
think you have to accept the dead ends
let me say let's let's put it that way
well yeah enjoy the suffering of it so
i i the way i think about it
i do uh doesn't uh i don't enjoy the
suffering it pisses me off but i
accept that it's part of the process
it's interesting there's a lot of ways
to kind of deal with that dead end
there's a guy who's ultra marathon run
on navy seal david goggins
who kind of i mean there's a certain
philosophy of like
most people would quit here
and so if most people would quit here
and i don't i'll have an opportunity to
discover something beautiful that others
haven't yet
like and any feeling that really sucks
it's like
okay most people would would just like
go do something smarter
if i stick with this um i will discover
a new
garden of uh fruit trees that i can pick
okay you say that but like
what about the guy who like wins the
nathan's hot dog eating contest every
year like when he eats his 35th hot dog
he like correctly says like okay most
people would stop here
like are you like lauding that he's like
no i'm going to eat the 32 i am i
am i am in the in the long arc of
history
that man is onto something
you